[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv 78 26 minutes pour faire
le tour de l'actualité elle local tout
de suite les titres de ce mardi 16
octobre le conflit se consume depuis le
début du mois d'octobre les maires de
voisins-le-bretonneux et de magny les
hameaux ont eu des échanges virulents
sur les réseaux sociaux
un motif de la discorde le projet d'une
voie de contournement par le sud deux
voisins qui dévierait le trafic vers
manille elle les explications à suivre
dans cette édition à la semaine dernière
les experts du giec qui a publié leur
ultime rapport sur le climat ils les
appellent les décideurs politiques à
limiter le réchauffement à 1,5 degré
plutôt qu à deux degrés que faut-il
retenir de cette nouvelle alerte du
monde scientifique éléments de réponse
avec françois du lac chercheur au
laboratoire des sciences du climat
alors est-ce qu enfin c'est une première
en france la l'assurance maladie des
yvelines lance une plateforme
collaborative jusqu'au 31 décembre elle
collecte et les bonnes idées et des
assurés pour en parler elodie breton de
la cpam des yvelines vous l'avez
peut-être remarqué si vous êtes balader
récemment à l'espace saint quentin une
boutique éphémère a ouvert ses portes au
sein du centre commercial
c'est une boutique pas comme les autres
jusqu'à la mi novembre environ quinze
jeunes y travailleront pour mettre en
pratique leur formation aux métiers du
commerce
ils vendront des vêtements de création
française et responsable une initiative
lancée également à marseille et beauvais
par l' ong catholique des apprentis
d'auteuil qui accompagne 25000 jeunes en
difficulté chaque année écouter ses
propos au micro de patrick jacques de
dixmude une boutique éphémère parce
qu'aujourd'hui les entreprises
attendent des compétences assez précises
et des temps de formation réduite
chez les jeunes on a qui sont souvent
des parcours scolaires un peu chaotique
ils veulent aussi une formation qui leur
permettent de mettre directement et
rapidement en application ce qu'ils
apprennent et de rentrer sur le marché
du travail
et après cette expérience au sein de la
boutique éphémère ces jeunes devraient
être recrutés par les enseignes de
l'espace saint quentin qui ont un besoin
supplémentaire en personnel à la proche
du rush des fêtes de fin d'année je vous
le disais dans les titres la circulation
anime en ce moment les maires de magny
les hameaux et de voisins-le-bretonneux
alexandra rosetti maire de voisins
propose de créer une déviation censé
désengorger le centre ville traversée
par des milliers d'automobilistes chaque
jour une voie de contournement à qui a
passerait par la commune de magny les
hameaux de quoi susciter la colère de
son maire bertrand ou lyon les détails
avec ce sujet de manon varaldo patrick
jacques de dixmude et nicolas landry
voisins le bretonneux se situe au
carrefour des axes routiers qui relie la
vallée de chevreuse à versailles et
saint quentin en yvelines le
développement du plateau de saclay fait
que chaque jour cette circulation
augmente dans la commune pour mettre fin
aux embouteillages et la mère de
voisins-le-bretonneux propose une
solution créer une voie de contournement
passant par magny les hameaux
afin de soulager la circulation sur la d
36 où on s'est dit ça arrange ça peut
arranger ses habitants aussi c'est à
dire ça peut leur éviter aussi des
bouchons des embouteillages mais il ya
vraiment la question environnementale
qui est très prégnante et que est qui et
qui n'est pas contournable à ce jour
alors est ce que quand la ligne 18 va
arriver est ce que ça peu cette nature à
débloquer des shows ou a poussé l'état
nous aider dans d'autres solutions
aujourd'hui j'ai pas la réponse une idée
communiqué dans le journal municipal de
septembre sans en avertir le maire de
magny les hameaux
j'étais surpris de cette proposition
mais surtout le lendemain je me suis
aperçu en lisant le magazine municipal
de voisins-le-bretonneux que cette
solution elle avait déjà été disputées
largement en amont avec le département
avec le député également ce que j'ai
trouvé
particulièrement irrespectueux dans le
cadre des relations intercommunales
qu'on peut avoir
et puis je considère que c'est comme ça
qu'on travaille
la proposition implique de construire un
viaduc en pleine zone forestière classée
natura 2000 et d'ouvrir une nouvelle
voie de circulation au travers du parc
régional de la haute vallée de chevreuse
une conférence de presse commune inédite
a été organisée entre les groupes
d'opposition de voisins-le-bretonneux il
demande d'être associés au travail de la
ville sur la circulation
nous arrivons à un moment important de
la vie de notre vie nous avons un projet
à la remise 500 logements et nous avons
un carrefour qui est inadaptée nous
avons pas le début d'un projet
concernant ce carrefour vous avez la rue
de la mérantaise où il véhicule circule
entre 7h30 et 8h30
que faisons nous il est temps d'agir et
c'est ce que nous disons à jurançon pour
voisin les deux maires partage toutefois
le même objectif désengorger les routes
des voitures qui traversent en nombre
leurs communes autre conflit celui ci au
sein à des élus de la majorité de
coignières qui a poussé le maire à la
démission et à l'organisation de
nouvelles élections municipales pour ce
scrutin partiel programmée le 25
novembre et 2 décembre ali bousselham a
confirmé qu'il serait tête de liste
après dhabi peines il s'agit du deuxième
candidat à se lancer au sein de
l'ancienne majorité municipale est 2e
adjoint de coignières ali et bousselham
était entré en opposition avec le maire
jean pierre sauvestre notamment après le
projet de fusion avec maurepas ensuite
abandonnée il indique être en train de
constituer sa liste pour cette
municipale à montigny le bretonneux un
salon la rénovation énergétique étaient
au programme ce dimanche à la ferme du
manet est l'occasion pour les visiteurs
de rencontrer à des professionnels et
d'échanger avec eux sur leurs projets de
rénovation énergétique reportage de
mickaël millero faire des économies tout
en faisant un geste pour la planète
c'était l'objectif de ce deuxième salon
de la rénovation énergétique organisée
ce dimanche 14 octobre à la ferme du
manet à monti le brunch
y avait un besoin des particuliers de se
renseigner sur cette thématique parce
qu'on entend beaucoup de choses c'est
vraiment en vogue on entend parler
partout mais pour avoir un conseil
précis et qu'il soit adapté
il ya vraiment rien de cette demande de
structures en fait cette année le salon
composer une thermographie aérienne
gratuite pour les visiteurs les caméras
infrarouges ont survolé en mars les
villes de saint quentin en yvelines pour
effectuer leur diagnostic sur la toiture
des bâtiments
on valide finalement par l'image les
endroits où ils ont pu réaliser des
travaux
et puis al'inverse pour des gens qui au
contraire ont des problèmes d'isolation
la réalisation de la thermographie
aérienne va permettre de précisément
indiquer les endroits où il faut
focaliser les travaux d'isolation un
stand qui a attiré plusieurs centaines
de personnes sur la journée
disons que j'ai déjà été rassurés par le
fait que la thermographie montrer que
mon logement était déjà clairement bien
isolé après je regardais un petit peu
pour la mise en place éventuellement
d'autres solutions pour produire de
l'énergie ne reste plus qu'aux visiteurs
à se lancer dans un projet de rénovation
énergétique mais cela a un coût entre
10000 et 30000 euros en moyenne et on
continue à parler écologie dans ce
journal avec mon invité françois du lac
mon soir en soir vous êtes chercheur au
sein du laboratoire des sciences du
climat il est rattaché à l'observatoire
de versailles saint-quentin-en-yvelines
déjà avant de parler du sujet pour
lequel vous êtes venu qu'est ce que ce
laboratoire est sûre quel domaine vous
travaillez précisément alors le
laboratoire d'une des sciences du climat
et de l'environnement je précise est un
laboratoire qui dépend de l'université
versailles saint quentin mais aussi du
cnrs et du ceva et on s'intéresse un tas
de clés de thématiques environnementales
et climatiques et en particulier il ya
dans ce laboratoire de grosses équipes
qui font de la modélisation du climat
mais aussi des gens qui s'intéressent
aux archives climatique à travers les
glaces polaires les sédiments marins et
beaucoup d'autres traceur il ya plus de
300 personnes qui travaillent dans ce
laboratoire et on parle justement climat
avec vous les experts scientifiques du
giec le groupe d'experts
intergouvernemental sur l'evolution
l'évolution du climat a publié la
semaine dernière un rapport il alerte
les décideurs publics sur la nécessité
de limiter le réchauffement climatique à
un degré et demi au lieu des 2 degrés
souvent avancés en termes d'objectifs
politiques et aussi de négociations il
appelle également à de grandes
transformations que retenez-vous de ce
rapport d'abord il faut se souvenir que
c'était une commande qui avait été faite
au giec
à la suite de la coop 21 et des accords
de paris de sortir un rapport spécial
parce que sinon le rythme des missions
des rapports du giec
et sur un temps plus long donc là le
scientifique en fait eu à travailler
beaucoup plus rapidement pour faire un
rapport si blessures finalement les
conséquences d'un réchauffement à 1,5 ou
à 2 degrés et qu'elle sera quels
seraient les impacts et donc qu'on peut
retenir en deux mots c'est qu'il ya une
bonne nouvelle 1 5 degré de
réchauffement moyen la surface de la
terre c'est encore possible
pas pour longtemps et ça va demander des
transformations radicales dans tous les
secteurs de la société qui aujourd'hui
sont basés sur les énergies fossiles
on va voir ça avec vous dans un assaut à
ce que d'après vous il va être crédible
ce que les décideurs publics vont
écouter ces experts du giec est ce qu'il
sera reçu 0 cet organisme le giec est en
fait est un organisme qui est issu des
nations unies et c'est non seulement un
groupe de scientifiques mais c'est aussi
des représentants des gouvernements et
le rapport est co signée par l'ensemble
des représentants des 195 parties
internationales on a peu d'espoir qu'il
soit donc ils avalisent au moins les
conclusions des scientifiques
après le fait que ce soit écoutée ou pas
si vous voulez les engagements qui ont
été pris jusqu'à maintenant nous amène
sur des trajectoires à +3 degrés donc il
va falloir faire des efforts et on
espère que la coop va servir aux états
et ça a été prévu pour ça à revaloriser
leurs efforts pour qu'on ait un
échauffement qui tendent au minimum vers
les 2 degrés quand nous sommes déjà à
mi-parcours en termes de réchauffement
il est déjà estimé à environ 1 degrés
d'après les derniers chiffres de 2010
est est ce que ce réchauffement vous
disiez tout à l'heure un degré et demi
il est possible vous le disiez c'est
possible oui oui tout à fait
les trajectoires montre que ça reste
possible mais on n'est pas du tout sur
les bonnes trajectoires actuellement la
france a encore eu plus de + 3 % en
augmentation de ses émissions de gaz à
effet de serre en 2017
il va falloir nous mettre sur une
trajectoire qui est de -7 % par an donc
on n'y est pas du tout et pour y arriver
il faut vraiment jouer de façon massive
sur tous les secteurs de l'économie que
ce soit la production d'énergie les
transports le bâtiment l'agriculture et
donc c'est vraiment c'est vraiment une
pression sur les gouvernements pour
qu'il ya un effort sans précédent qu'il
soit fait les différences notables y
aurait une différence notable entre un
réchauffement entre 1 degré et demi un
réchauffement à 2 degrés tout à fait en
fait les toutes les études d'impact qui
ont qui ont été faites récemment et les
quelques unes qui avait été fait
auparavant montrent que en fait chaque
2000 degrés a une importance capitale on
a des on a des effets qui sont pas du
tout linéaire avec le réchauffement
pour vous donner un exemple frappant on
s'attend avec plus 1,5 degré à perdre
entre 70 et 90 % des récifs coralliens à
deux degrés on les perd pratiquement
tous à plus de 99%
donc il ya vraiment des dommages pour
les écosystèmes pour les sociétés
humaines qui sont sans commune mesure à
2 degrés par rapport à 1,5 et évidemment
si on va à 3 la trajectoire sur laquelle
se sont aujourd'hui engagés les états on
aura encore des impacts très supérieur
et sur l'évolution du niveau des mers
qu'en est il également
alors c'est pareil il ya en gros on
estime la différence sur le niveau des
mers à à 10 cm entre 1 5 et 2 degrés
mais dix centimètres de niveau des mers
ses 10 millions de personnes sur les
zones côtières à déplacer et donc
évidemment ça a un impact non
négligeable
les projections nous annonce qu'avec ce
réchauffement climatique on va devoir
déplacer des centaines de millions de
personnes
quand on voit la difficulté aujourd'hui
qu'on a accueilli quelques dizaines de
milliers de migrants on imagine le bazar
que ça va mettre à l'échelle mondiale
quand vous voyez dans le même temps
qu'avec ce rapport du giec il ya aussi
des échos sceptiques
on le voit notamment des propos du
président trump le président américain
on va pas forcément dans la bonne
trajectoire il ya les bons propos sont
pas forcément utilisés non
si vous voulez aujourd'hui je pense
qu'il n'y a plus aucun doute à avoir sur
la réalité du réchauffement climatique
et sur la responsabilité des activités
humaines là dedans ce qui pourrait
gagner maintenant les gens finalement
c'est plutôt un climato fatalisme c'est
à dire que voilà ça va être tellement
difficile que y'a rien à faire reposons
nous sur des espoirs de solutions
technologiques it ou permettrait
peut-être d'ici quelques dizaines
d'années de stocker massivement du
carbone atmosphérique dans les sous-sols
partition j'allais vous lancer sur ça
justement comment on se donne les moyens
aujourd'hui de limiter ce réchauffement
un degré et demi le rapport préconise
notamment une réduction de 45% des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et ce
d'ici à 2034 est déjà une une première
voie alors c'est absolument
indispensable d'atteindre ce niveau là
effectivement et plus on retarde la
diminution plus on fait un pari énorme
sur le futur en imaginant qu'on aura des
solutions technologiques pour enfouir
des dizaines de milliards de tonnes de
co2 dans le sol ou dans les fonds
océaniques et aujourd'hui c'est vraiment
un pari sur les générations futures
insensé de faire ça alors moi je
voudrais quand même faire la publicité
aujourd'hui ses efforts pour la
transition énergétique ça représente des
investissements de de plusieurs
centaines pouvoir supérieur à 1000
milliards d'euros par an pour l'europe
et donc ce sont aujourd'hui les sommes
que la banque centrale européenne et
mais tous les ans pour soutenir
l'économie et qui sont mis à disposition
des banques donc il ya une initiative
aujourd'hui qui sait vous pouvez trouver
sur internet climat attiré 2020 qui
consiste à dire mettons ces 1000
milliards d'euros par an au service du
climat et la transition énergétique et
lançons un véritable plan marshall à
l'échelle de l'europe pour vraiment
tenir cet objectif de 1,5 degré merci
françois du lac d'avoir été avec eux et
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes chercheur au
laboratoire des sciences du climat et de
l'environnement à l'eau vs cul pour plus
d'information d'ailleurs sur vos
recherches invite les téléspectateurs à
se rendre sur le site internet qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran
du côté de maurepas on fêtait les
commerces et les artisans pour la
journée nationale du commerce de
proximité 20 boutiques de la ville se
sont mobilisés
objectif renforcer le lien avec la
clientèle et faire découvrir les métiers
du commerce marylène iapichino pour la
journée nationale du commerce de
proximité la ville de maurepas hélas
sont des commerçants de la commune ont
investi la place du sancerrois des
animations étaient proposées toute la
journée pour faire découvrir leur métier
nous avons une esthéticienne enfin
pierre de derrière qui permet aux
clients de venir jouer et donc on essaie
d'animer la place pour que les gens
profitent de cette journée bien
ensoleillée et que les clés comment les
commerçants présentent leur métier
exposition sur la laine à tricoter qu
dégustation à la boulangerie en plus des
stands installés les commerçants réservé
un accueil spécial aux clients au sein
même de leurs boutiques pour qu'ils nous
lâchent qu'ils continuent à venir chez
nous à nous faire travailler
c'est important pour la ville pour faire
vivre le centre ville nous faire vivre
c'est la cinquième année que maurepas
participent à cette journée nationale
sur les trente membres de l'association
des commerçants 20 se sont mobilisés ce
qui vaut à la ville une récompense de 2
sourire du comité national du commerce
de proximité
les sourires récompense la synergie
entre la
la ville et l'union des commerçants un
dossier est envoyé auprès de
l'association gncp qui est la journée
nationale du commerce de proximité
ils viennent aussi vérifier sur place ce
qui se passe comme animation ils vont
visiter les commerces qui participent et
en fonction
en fonction de ce qu'ils ont vu ils vont
décerner jusqu'à 4 sourire la ville et
ses commerçants souhaitent déjà
participé à leur sixième édition et
pourquoi pas obtenir un troisième
sourire la deuxième invitée avec moi sur
ce plateau elodie breton bonsoir d'un
soir vous êtes responsable développement
innovation à la cpam des yvelines acpm
qui lance pour ce mois d'octobre et
jusqu'au 31 décembre une plateforme
inédite elle sert à collecter les bonnes
idées des assurés pour améliorer vos
services on en discute juste ce chiffre
pour commencer il ya 1 million 400 mille
bénéficiaires de l'assurance maladie
dans les yvelines pourquoi lancer cette
plateforme cette plateforme pardon
auprès de ses bénéficiaires
alors pourquoi lancer cette plateforme
l'idée est venue quand on a regardé les
villes qui construisaient avec leurs
usagers on s'est dit pourquoi pas nous
assurance maladie cpam des yvelines ne
construirions nous pas également avec
nos usagers nos assurés sociaux
c'est la raison pour laquelle on a
décidé de lancer sa plateforme alors
qu'on s'est lancé en 2017
c'est quelque chose qui existe déjà dans
les marques de consommation courante qui
existent aussi chez nos cousins de la
ratp la sncf mais qui n'existaient pas
jusqu'à lors au sein de l'assurance
maladie donc on a décidé de se lancer
sur ce projet vous disiez c'était tester
c'est ça en 2017 dès 2010 elles vous
l'avez testé cette fête alors on a
commencé à monter le projet en 2017
on a réalisé une enquête d'opinion
auprès de nos assurés et on a essayé de
recueillir les thèmes qu'il sur lesquels
ils préféreraient nous donner leurs
idées et c'est aujourd'hui ces thèmes
que vous retrouverez sur cette
plateforme
vous vouliez ce cette initiative ne se
faisait pas encore dans l'assurance
maladie c'est vous êtes la première cpm
de france a lancé cette innovation il
c'était important pour vous d'être les
premiers à lancer cette plateforme alors
pour nous c'était plutôt important de se
d'aller recueillir les idées nos assurés
sociaux plutôt que d'être les premiers
nous ce qu'on recherche vraiment c'est
la co-construction avec les usagers et
la recherche d'amélioration continue on
est convaincu que c'est en retournant à
la source et en allant chercher les
idées de nos usagers qu'on va réussir à
s'améliorer dans sept ans contre 1 qui
sont ceux actuellement du coup quels
sont les objectifs concret c'est c'est
d'écouter ses assurés alors les
objectifs concrets c'est effectivement
d'écouter les assurés de recueillir
leurs bonnes idées entre maintenant et
fin décembre on est en expérimentation
si ça fonctionne on pense à l'étendre à
nos autres usagers qui sont les
entreprises les employeurs et les
professionnels de santé mais vraiment
l'objectif principal c'est de recueillir
toutes les idées possibles et libre
imagination
alors comment ça marche concrètement
comment on soumet ses bonnes alors pour
soumettre votre bonne idée vous vous
connectez sur la plateforme sur notre
site internet d'ici peu sa fiche
actuellement vous entrez votre
pseudonyme et vous déposez votre idée si
vous pouvez également en profiter pour
commenter les idées des autres et ça
c'est important parce qu'on compte aussi
sur le fait que le groupe rebondit sur
les idées de ses pairs et sur quelle
thématique quelles idées on peut on peut
soumettre sur la plateforme
alors vous pouvez soumettre des idées
qui nous permet d'imaginer ensemble
agence d'accueil du futur puisqu'on a
aujourd'hui 15 points d'accueil dans
notre département
vous pouvez également rebondir ou en
tout cas imaginer un nouveau moyen des
changes avec nous on a eu une idée d'un
assuré social qui nous disaient mais
pourquoi ne faites pas vous rendez vous
ne faites vous pas vous rendez vous en
visioconférence pourquoi pas
effectivement ça c'est vrai ça qui est
exclusivement aux bénéficiaires des
yvelines oui ça s'adresse plutôt aux
assurés linois même si évidemment on
recueille les idées de toutes les
personnes qui les déposeront mais étant
une cpam affiliés à notre département
c'est plutôt les yvelinois donc le
soumettre donc ses idées jusqu'au 31
décembre est ce que vous êtes fixé un
objectif en termes du nombre d'idées
combien d'idées attendez vous alors on
aimerait recueillir
au moins 300 idées et essayer d'en
développer une ou plusieurs dans les six
mois
c'est à dire avant juin 2019 donc vous
l'avez dit c'est jusqu'au 31 décembre
ensuite qu'est ce qui va se passer alors
ensuite ce qui va se passer c'est qu'on
va réaliser un bilan on va analyser tout
ce qu'on reçoit on va trier on va
inviter les dépositeurs les des poseurs
de bonnes idées à nous rejoindre il ya
aller travailler
cette fois ci en présentiel et non par
an virtuelle sous forme d'ateliers et
puis les mettre en oeuvre et les
expérimentés quelles sont vos ambitions
qu est ce qui ferait que voilà ce cette
première plateforme soit une réussite et
que vous reconduisez cette opération par
la suite alors pour nous une réussite ce
serait que les yvelinois ils trouvent un
espace imaginatif de co-création avec
nous et puis ceux déposés dont je vous
lise est à peu près enfin plusieurs
idées en tout cas qu'on puisse
accueillir 300 un critère de réussite
pour nous ce serait aussi qu'on puisse
réussir à les mettre en oeuvre
simplement et rapidement et que les
assurés qui est déposé leurs idées voir
concrètement ce que ça donne je serais
ce que vous espérez être aussi
précurseur pour d'autres assurances
maladie et de france dans d'autres
départements
alors pourquoi pas si nos voisin
francilien en ile-de-france où ou sur le
territoire
veulent se lancer avec nous on n'est pas
opposé à apprêter le dispositif et les
générer de la plateforme
merci elodie breton d'avoir été avec
nous je rappelle que vous êtes
responsable du développement et
d'innovation à la cpam des yvelines et
ses bonnes idées vous pouvez donc les
soumettre sur cette plateforme
collaborative jusqu'au 31 décembre
le site s affiche en bas de l'écran
merci beaucoup un mot de ce sport dans
le championnat de division d'honneur de
rugby versailles n'en finit plus de
gagner ce week-end le club a engrangé sa
quatrième victoire de la saison en
autant de matches succès 26 à 9 contre
le rc paris 15 retour sur cette
rencontre avec michael et demi d'euros
les versaillais peuvent laisser éclater
leur joie l'équipe a encore réalisé une
grosse prestation à domicile ce dimanche
14 octobre contre paris 15 versa il
emporte 26 à 9 avec quatre essais
inscrits y conserve son invincibilité
on a eu un petit passage un petit peu un
temps faible en fin de première période
on a revu les bouchées doubles en début
début de deuxième mi temps et sait gérer
pas que ce sens force l on a few
confiance qu'une chanson de force on est
au dessus dans le sens où la confiance
on a confiance en nos forces et quand on
arrive à jouer simplement on peut
arriver à mettre en difficulté n'importe
qui on est très contents très satisfait
l'engagement dégâts et de ce qu'ils
produisent à l'entraînement donc on est
sur la bonne la bonne voie avec cette
victoire les joueurs de la cité royale
s'envole déjà au classement l'équipe
compte quatre points d'avancé sur clichy
après seulement quatre journées dans ce
championnat de division honneur
malgré cette place de leader les
versaillais ne veulent pas s'enflammer
l'excès de confiance a lancé un partout
dans la vie c'est comme ça dès qu'on a
un peu trop d'excès je pense que
derrière on peut avoir des déconvenues
donc
voilà il faut rester vigilant travail et
bossez continuer parce que bon il ya la
montée en fédérale 3 mais au prix il yal
aventure aussi humaine avec avec les
garçons et encore plein de matches le
premier est le plus important c'est de
faire un premier bloc
le premier bloc des quatre matchs de
faire que des victoires on s'attendait
pas à prendre le temps de 32,9 au bonus
offensif france surtout qu'on taise
équipe commerce et et 15 aides en six
tours nous c'est tout bon pour continuer
à régner sur la division honneur
l'armada offensive versaillaise ira
défier le 11 novembre prochain le
clermont club rugby sur son terrain et
pour l'instant les joueurs peuvent
savourer comme tous les mardis mélanie
poker nous a rejoint un plateau bonsoir
votre coup de coeur de la semaine fait
souffler un vent de liberté de par sa
thématique mais aussi par les
comédiennes qui sont sur scène alors il
s'agit de année ça ludivine shirin dan
alors elle habille inès maureen yasmina
dix jeunes femmes
leur point commun elles sont toutes
issues de quartiers populaires et sont
novices flammes et leur première scène
le metteur en scène
ahmed madani poursuit sa recherche
artistique avec des jeunes nés de
parents immigrés certains sont d'origine
algérienne ivoirienne ou encore créole
j'ai pas l'histoire déchirante à vous
raconter
vous voyez le genre de truc
je porte un lourd fardeau nous sommes
issus d'un peuple qui a beaucoup
souffert
la tragique histoire de ma mère la
tragique histoire de mon père si pour
toi être un homme c'est de frapper une
femme à leur propre moi mais ma mère
aime pousser toujours à l'école vit
laisse plein et moi je veux que mes
enfants aillent à l'école
mon père m'a sous les avec barry white
est ce qui fait que ça marche mélanie
c'est que les comédiennes jouent en fait
leur propre rôle dans vos rôles elle se
confiait au public leur histoire celle
de leur famille celle de leur quotidien
le public entre ainsi dans l'intimé
flamme est en fait le deuxième volet
d'une trilogie km madani a nommé face à
leur destin lors le premier volet le
signe en 2012 avec des jeunes hommes du
val fourré ça s'appelait illuminations
ahmed madani mail en général fiction et
réalité est là aussi tout par des
comédiennes sensible
le principe était de ne pas commencer à
écrire un seul mot avant que l'équipe
soit rassemblée sur le sur le plateau
j'ai travaillé pendant deux ans en
immersion on rencontre en deux jeunes
femmes en leur posant des questions
qu'elle était capable de me livrer de
cette choses intimes en elle et de delà
de la partager ensuite avec le les
spectateurs alors ahmed madani a
rencontré des centaines de jeunes femmes
dix d'entre elles ont accepté de monter
sur scène elle parle donc mais elle
chante aussi
elle mime elle danse ce qui en ressort
c'est surtout l'honnêteté de ces jeunes
film n'est tout est rafraîchissante qui
rassemble aussi les critiques
médiatiques et du public au public saint
quentinois cette fois de se laisser
embarquer flamme est à voir au théâtre
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines du 17 au 20
octobre
merci mélanie à suivre après ce journal
votre émission hebdomadaire le 7-8
culture on referme cette édition sur ces
images pour le moins craquante deux
bébés panthères de chine ont vu le jour
récemment au zoo safari de thoiry elle
n'a au lit à l'image est née fin juillet
depuis peu le public peut le voir la
voir en compagnie de sa mère china et il
ya quinze jours un autre petit a été
mise au monde par la femelle
qui aujourd'hui en milieu naturel il
reste moins de 2500 panthères de chine
c'est la fin de ce journal le replay est
à retrouver sur notre site internet et
notre application mobile belle soirée
avec tv 78
[Musique]